each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello it's my pleasure to introduce you
gran chamber he's visiting us from
barking and talking about the strength
of linear in semi definite programs so
thanks everyone for showing up to my
talk talk about the strength of linear
and semi definite programs you've all
said you've heard several talks on this
topic before so I change things around
from the normal talk and hopefully it'll
help put things in context and it won't
be so into the details as some of the
talks so I hope you enjoy it um the
setting is we have these combinatorial
optimization problems and we know how to
how do you get we know that you can't
solve them exactly there NP hard in
general solve exactly and so you might
say well are they all the same and
people said no they're not all the same
because actually some of them you can
approximate well and some of them you
can't approximately well and a lot of
the recent work in theoretical computer
science has been pinning down how well
you can approximate these problems and
we've pinned this down pretty well for a
large swath of these problems but
problems that look like traveling
salesman problem or problems that are
too csps which means that kind of very
have local constraints and each
constraint only depends on two variables
these we've been rather unsuccessful at
pinning down the approximation factories
we do have at least non-trivial
approximation algorithms for these
problems and some examples of these are
the La Voz beta function this max cut
algorithm by Gomez and Williamson and
the ARV sparse is cut algorithm so and
these kind of successful algorithms are
all based on a semi definite programming
so kind of a useful technique seems to
be semi definite programming and I the
as we'll see kind of later there's
obvious ways to make these semi definite
programs stronger and one of the main
oval questions is do these techniques
help so can we get stronger or better
approximation algorithms kind of without
thinking too hard for these problems
so today I'm going to focus on one
particular problem which is vertex cover
so in vertex cover you're given a graph
and you want to find a minimal kind of
cover so a cover is a set of vertices
such that each edge is incident to at
least one vertex in the cover so you
want to find a minimal size cover and
this is this problems NP hard but we can
approximate it and there's a simple two
approximation which I'll show soon it's
been shown to be np-hard to compute
exactly better than 1.36 this is by
dinner and safra actually it's unique
games hard to come to do better than two
and we're interested in how well can
these linear programs and our semi
definite programs do even in even in
just like barely sub exponential time
can we get better than a two
approximation for these using these
techniques so to define things a little
bit the first thing I'll kind of define
what a linear program relaxation here is
so you start off with an integer program
so we encode the vertex cover problem as
an integer program so for each vertex in
the graph we're going to introduce a
variable the variable is going to be one
if the verdict is in the cover zero if
the vertex is not in the cover and so
we're trying to minimize over the sum of
these variables which is the number of
variables in the cover and for each edge
we add a constraint that says that you
know the sum of the end points is
greater than one which means one of them
must be in the cover so all I've done
here I haven't done anything I've just
rewritten vertex cover as an integer
program vertex cover was NP complete so
as integer programming so nothing's
happened but the kind of amazing thing
is that if we relax this and we add more
possible solutions and we say just
anything between zero and one is ok now
I have a linear program i can solve it
but now i'm solving a different problem
what I set up solve and this notion of
the integrality gap captures kind of the
relation between the linear program and
the integer program so what it is is
it's the the ratio between in kind of
the the worst case of the combinatorial
optimum / linear programming optimum so
this this racial be large
if there's any instance where the linear
program optimum gets much better right
because it relaxing it so the
minimization is going to decrease so if
it gets much better than the integer
program and so we can see here the
integrality gap is actually two more or
less it's less than 2 by rounding if you
just solve the linear program you get
these fractional solutions and we're
just going to round the fraction to 0 or
1 and at most the weight of the total
solution can double because one half can
go to one and that's doubling that's
that's the most i can do you notice that
if the constraints are satisfied before
the rounding they're satisfied after
because if the sum of the constraints
was greater than one one of them must be
greater than one half that one will
round 21 so the integers solution will
also be a solution here so you get that
the integral gap is less than 2 by by
rounding and so in particularly this
gives you an algorithm and you can see
it's greater than 2 also and the way to
that is you have the complete graph
that's going to be our counter example
here it has no small vertex cover so
that smallest vertex covers n minus 1
but the linear program gives an optimum
of event over 2 and the reason is that
you can put 1 half everywhere if you put
when a half everywhere all these
constraints are satisfied so it claims
the kind of found a vertex cover of size
half the vertices but no such vertex
cover exists and so the ratio between
kind of n minus 1 and 1 over 2 is is too
so you get the integrality got being at
least two here so let's just kind of
review what what happened here what
happened is we started off with an
integer program and you can look at the
convex combinations of the valid
integral solutions and then we relax the
program when we relaxed at this kind of
polytope became bigger and admitted kind
of bad solutions to it okay now you
might object to this being saying that
this complete graph is kind of a obvious
counter example and we can we can get
rid of that pretty easily by just saying
it has triangles in it so any triangle
at least two of the vertices must be in
the cover so I'm going to add another
constraint that says that you know for
any triangle in the graph the sum of the
the vertices corresponding to them must
be at least two okay and now the
previous counterexample doesn't work
right and a question is well what's the
integrality got peer and the answer is
it's still too you need to be more
clever to define a counterexample but
it's still too and so then what so we
have the integer convex company integral
solutions we relax at two linear
solutions and then this essentially
creates a cut on these on these
solutions that we have making the
polytope smaller and the question is
kind of can we make these cuts enough to
get it back so that the two actually
shrink the integrality gap and you see
while the complete graph was removed as
a counterexample equally bad
counter-examples still exists here so
let's just do it one more time this time
with semi definite programming okay so
this is kind of almost doing the exact
same thing with semi definite
programming so we start off with our
integer program here I wrote it a little
differently so instead of the some
constraint I have that the product
equals zero so at least one of them must
be one it's all that saying you can
rewrite it by just homogenizing it so
now I don't have any degree 1 terms
that's all I did here so these are these
are squared and that doesn't actually
change anything so i equals i squared
means that X i equals x i' squared means
that x is 0 or 1 those are only two
solutions there so here i add i add
another variable that's essentially one
so you can think of X naught as being
one it could be minus one but it doesn't
change things so just think of it being
one and then i take x i' squared which
is the same as X I and minimizing sum
over this and i have i replaced this
constraint here by just multiplying by
one their which doesn't change anything
and i replace the one by x not there
so I haven't changed anything yet I just
homogenized it but now from here we can
actually relax and we can say well
instead of using these uh these scalars
allow any vectors and so that this is a
relaxation and now I just get this goofy
looking a program over here which again
is solvable in polynomial time because
it's a semi definite program and now the
question is what's the relation between
the solutions of this program the the
semi definite program and the integral
program and it was shown by Kleinberg
and Goldman's 98 that the integrality
gap is still essentially two and they
use this this kind of a special graph or
kind of family of graphs to do this all
these frankel rodle graphs which will
come up more in the future too but what
I want to say about this is that so if
you have an integral T gap it kind of
requires three main components one is
you need the counterexample itself which
here is going to be a Frankel rodle
graph so the Franklin roto graph is you
have the vertices of their vertices the
hypercube and your each vertex is
connected to the points that are almost
in typical to it so if you connect each
vertex to its antipodal point in a
hypercube you get a matching right and a
matching actually has a vertex cover of
size a half its matching okay this graph
is geometrically very similar instead of
connecting tins the typical point each
points calculative points that are
almost in typical to it and so
geometrically it looks kind of like a
matching but in fact it's not okay so
the next two components you need of the
integrality got to show an in gravity
gap is you need to show one that this
graph actually this counter example who
does not have a small vertex cover which
is what Franklin rodle showed that this
kind of graph where you connect things
almost antipodal points has no small
vertex cover any vertex cover is almost
the entire graph and you also need to
show a semi definite solution
to the problem that obtains that shows
that kind of the semi definite program
finks there is a good solution to this
and hear what what they did with these
Francoeur autographs is they were able
to create solutions kind of with the
intuition I told you before that
geometrically this this graph looks very
similar to matching even though it's
common travel behavior is far from that
so kleinberg and Goldman's created this
stp solution that satisfies this for the
Frank Carollo graphs which showed in
Raleigh gap is too but again you can
introduce very simple kind of additional
equations to it so here we add one that
says X I times XJ is greater than zero
which is always true for these integral
solutions and that adds the the
corresponding constraint that VI VJ is
greater than 0 and this it turns out
this equation was not satisfied in the
Kleinberg and Goldman's solution so kind
of if you just increase the the program
a little bit it's not satisfied anymore
jerker showed that it was you could kind
of you could tweak it and satisfy it
again but what I'm point about here is
kind of this cat and mouse game between
kind of creating better cuts and then
better integrality gaps and then better
cuts and then better integrality gaps
and then better cut some better in rally
gaps and and and so kind of the the goal
of this line of research is to
systematize this and and to try to get
rid of the cat and mouse game though
perhaps it just creates at a larger
scale and and say what it means to kind
of rule out large swathes of these
linear and semi definite programs so the
weight the way we're going to do this is
to think of things as distributions so
we have we're dealing with convex
programs so we can't help but include
all convex combinations
of valid integral solutions otherwise we
won't have a convex program but we want
to so the kind of thought is once a lot
only these things it's not only these
things so a convex combination of
integral solutions can be thought of as
a distribution over integral solutions
which is kind of a little strange but so
someone comes to you and says well I
don't have one in a real solution but I
have a whole bunch of them and here's a
distribution over them okay and we have
to allow this and we'll see later why
this is maybe a good idea but just go
with me here for a second so a
distribution is just a map from the kind
of 0 1 unit interval 2012 the N we'll
think of things in vertex covers or this
so I have a map of assigned assignments
to the what vertices are in the cover
which vertices are outside of the cover
and I want these to be vertex covers and
I can encode this in this very
inefficient way which is kind of like a
probabilistic long code I guess so for
every function from 0 1 to the N 201 I
say what's the probability given your
distribution that function being
satisfied ok so if this function we're
just we're just kind of one on one on
one particular assignment and 0 the rest
you'd get kind of you know the nonzero
functions would be the support you'd see
the probability so you see this actually
gives you a distribution but it gives
you a lot more than that so examples of
kind of functions i could ask is like
what's the probability that x is in the
cup that x I is in the cover vertex eyes
on the cover what's probably that
protects eyes on the cover but verdict
is jay's not what's probability that
there's 10 vertices on the cover for
example and it turns out that you can if
someone gives you an encoding so they
give you kind of the the probability of
f4 aw laughs so think of this is a big
vector and they give you this vector you
can check that the vector is a valid you
know a probability distribution by
checking that this that you know this
thing holds the probability of f press
apology is just probably f ng + f or g
for all combinations here and you can
check
that the probability that kind of always
true thing is one probably all false one
is zero and and you can check that this
function that corresponds to kind of
valid vertex cover assignments is one or
correspondingly the one that corresponds
to invalid vertex cover science is zero
so you put zero weight on invalid vertex
cover assignments and all the weight
goes on valid ones okay so these are my
point is that these are things that you
can check with a linear program so I can
encode I'm giving this vector I can
encode kind of linear program i can
write a linear program that checks that
you give you gave me a legitimate
solution and so we can simplify this a
little bit one way to simplifies we only
we actually only need to check local
constraints so for for if IJ is an edge
we really only need to check that with
zero probability neither i nor Jays in
the vertex cover that that's enough so
we don't have to check this we can just
check these local constraints the reason
being if there's any weight on a on a on
an invalid vertex cover assignment then
if we have a true probability
distribution there'll be some weight on
a violate violated constraint ok so we
can check the constraints are always
invited and actually so this program
here is doubly exponential in size
because the number of functions is
double exponential in the number of
variables and you don't need this you
can actually restrict yourself to
conjunctions of literals but and then
it's exponential which is kind of the
way that will want to think about these
things being kind of exponential and
then not double exponential but i think
this notation is just easier so why use
this notation but it but it doesn't
really matter
II know I want d to be a distribution so
this is just like the probability space
and then you get a an assignment wait
what at the office okay so yeah so
well you can think of it that way I'm
just thinking of D being a random
variable but yeah
okay so now this is similar to what i
said before you can we want to minimize
this expression here which is just the
expected number of variables that are in
the cover and for all functions f we
have a a variable which is supposed to
be there kind of probability and we want
that to be between 0 and 1 and we expect
this to hold for our variables these
things that we have a valid assignment
this thing here to hold and then I just
rewrote this using kind of the
simplified things so maybe for each
conjunction you have a variable that's
probably between 0 and 1 and you check
that kind of the probability c is equal
to probability C&I plus C and not I so
still have conjunctions and the
probability of not I and not J should be
0 for every edge so I don't put any
weight on things that are violated and
so this this gives you a nice linear
program here right i just wrote it in
terms so you can see kind of how we get
from distribution to a linear program
and now we're going to do something a
little goofy that doesn't just to
complicate things a little more we're
going to trade this thing that that they
call a moment matrix and the rows and
the columns are going to be indexed by
these by these functions F and the IJ
entry is going to be the probability of
F and or the fgf entry is going to be
the probably F and G okay so I had this
vector of all these things and i'm going
to create kind of a matrix out of it and
the what are some things about this
matrix is that if we look at one row
it's kind of like everything in that if
we look at F throw everything that row
is kind of like and F and F right it's
like what's probably this and F happens
we'll probably that and F happens and so
if we divided by the probability of F
assuming it's nonzero it's kind of like
conditioning on F happening right
because the probably F and I / the part
of the f is a probability of I condition
on F so if these rows kind of normalized
it's like conditioning on an event and
when you condition you should all
we'll get a distribution of vertex
covers right because if I say all these
this is the distribution of vertex
covers and I condition on event then I
get another different distribution of
vertex covers and in particular in the
future will dick will condition on
dictators which are just like X I so
what's probably the excise on the cover
or let's condition on X I being being in
the cover and also up a property this
matrix is that it's positive
semi-definite and the reason is that if
you if you have an integral solution
then the matrix is just if Y is kind of
this vector this encoding vector we had
the matrix is just the outer product
this yty right because the probability
of F and G is one if F and G are both
true and zero if either f or g is zero
so it's just out of product here and
then the linear combination of positive
semi definite matrices is also positive
semi definite so ok let's go mate so we
have this moment matrix each row each
normalized row is like conditioning on
an element and each and it's positive
semi-definite why here why here why
would be yeah the it would be a row
vector but it'd be like the the row
vector corresponding to the row 1 ok so
now let's define some stuff let's do
something cool I'm going to rearrange
the vectors the order of these things in
a particular way and the way I'm going
to arrange them is so a function said to
depend on a variable if it's ever the
case that changing the value of that
variable changes the value of the
function and a function is a que Hunta
if it only depends on at most K
variables ok so we're going to put the 0
hunters first these are just the
constant functions that are always one
or 0 0 and then we have the one hunters
and these are just dictator functions or
anti dictator functions 100 and 200 and
300 and so on ok so now to get K rounds
of shali atoms
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
insist that you give me this kind of
truncated part of the moment matrix so
i'll require that you give me not all
the probabilities but all the
probabilities for you know say three
hunters single though right yeah exactly
yeah yeah a real lot of them okay so I'm
going to so if for vertex cover for
example i'm going to minimize over these
probability of the eyes there's some of
the probably eyes is that this is the
number of vertices that in the cover and
the the kind of paula to by minimizing
over is that this is the one to find
here it's it's the kind of assignments
that you can lift to this larger space
here legally i'm going to i'm going to i
as well those and these are just the
same constraints that we had before that
we said held for the entire moment
matrix we're just going to insist that
they hold on this small part here are
people following this at all is you
should ask questions at this point if
you're not is it won't get any better
actually this is this is the worst of it
i just say this is the worst of it so
but if you don't understand this it
won't get much better and then lacera
says that actually this matrix here is
positive semi definite so for the same
reason the whole matrix is positive semi
definite any sub matrix will be also
alright so given a solution i want to
lift it to this large space when i when
i say that you know a vertex cover
solution survives what i need to do is
define all the things on this kind of
section of the moment matrix and then
I've showed that it survives you know k
rounds of charlotte atoms or k run
zipless there okay and actually the so i
defined there's four hierarchies
I would find two of them now the the
other two are very similar to each other
and they actually use they use this
little box here this much smaller box
they just look at kind of zero hunt ISM
and one hunters and so the lavash ever
because you have some linear programming
you start with a linear program and you
say X long's the kind of the lifting of
the cylini er program if there's a
protection matrix so this is just the
moment matrix for all the one hunters so
i define kind of what's the probability
remember we said we could if we could
look at these roses kind of conditioning
on something so you say what's what's
the probability this is the probability
of kind of like X I being in it this is
probably of X I and X 1 X I and X 2 this
row here so I give the the moment matrix
for this and it turns out that the the
kind of consistency constraints now
reduced is simply checking that the that
the matrix is symmetric and that the
first row in the first column and the
diagonal are the same and this is just
these are just all the consistency
constraints that there that there are
the row is just conditioning on a and if
you condition on an event so the I throw
and you renormalize that this should
still belong to the initial cone so what
is saying is that if I condition on that
eyes and the vertex cover I should still
get a distribution that looks like a
distribution of vertex covers right and
so this is this is LS here and if we
want to do it we just do it intuitively
so we iterate it so if we want to do the
Arth level we insist that you know each
row belongs to the r minus 1 flavell
okay and so the way to kind of think of
this is that you know you you give a
protection matrix and then some say some
adversary says you know but what about
this row here show that this row belongs
to the r minus 1 and so then you take
that row you normalize it you give a
protection matrix for that and so
on and so forth so you can condition on
the variable and say show me what
happens when the eighth variable is in
the cover and then you give another
protection matrixes okay show me now
what happens in that condition
additionally the J throat X is not in
the cover so now I've conditioned that I
is in the cover and j is not in the
cover okay and I need a new protection
matrix um and so this kind of is similar
to what happens before right where I
have the the hunters I I can I can
condition on more than one thing
happening at once here right I can
condition that eyes and the cover and j
is not in the cover whereas here in LS I
condition the eyes in the coverage is in
the cover and I can give a protection
matrix that depends on the order in
which these variables were conditioned
on so I can give you a different matrix
if you first condition that J is not in
the cover and I is in the cover ok and
this means that lavash driver is is
weaker than charlie adams and
additionally you can you can include a
positive definite positive semi-definite
constraint here and this gives you LS
plus and in the same way do people
understand that a little bit okay so a
way to make it a little more concrete is
this prove your adversary game so the
pru versed i have this valid vertex
cover solution that looks that gives
these weights and here's a little
adversary and he says well show me what
happens when I condition on this vertex
here and so the prover has to give two
distributions of what happens when it's
not in the cover and when it is in the
cover so here it's not in the cover here
is in the cover this happens probability
two-thirds one-third and you can see if
you kind of multiply these weights by
two-thirds those weights by one-third
you get those weights up there and then
the next round the adversary says okay
tell me what happens when this vertex is
in the cover and not in the cover and
you say well if it's not in the cover
that the graph has to look like this
that's kind of all there is to do if it
is in the cover I'm stuck all right I
don't there's nothing I can do and so I
don't survive two rounds of of LS here
of course this is kind of a
character of it you need these
protection matrices but this is more or
less what's what's going on just to make
a more concrete and so the adver serious
is ha you know I got you ok so kind of
review we have these hierarchy of
hierarchies there's four hierarchies
that we saw there's the Shroud items i'm
gonna ser these ones have this is like
the semi definite constraint here and so
lacera is strictly stronger than charlie
adams because it has a semi definite
constraint LS plus is strictly stronger
than LS because it has a semi defense
right we saw before that the LS one's
kind of proceed in the washer /
preseason these rounds which means that
I can change my distributions depending
on what order things are conditioned in
so it makes it kind of easier to fool
them and so the LS is weaker than to
rally adams just as LS plus is weaker
than Lasserre so this is kind of and so
will will see some gaps for for all
those guys
okay these hierarchies all have certain
things in common they systematically add
more constraints after all after our
rounds you've added kind of all the
valid constraints on any subset of our
variables you've actually added much
more but you've at least got this and
this shows that it's tight after n
rounds because you had all valid
constraints on all variables you're
tight and it also runs in time into the
order are so this means that if we show
a lower bound against algorithms that
run for log and rounds we've ruled out
all Kwasi polynomial algorithms based on
these ideas here and if you rule out all
up to order n rounds you've ruled out
all sub exponential time algorithms and
super constant you wrote all paloma
algorithms so these capture interesting
algorithms in very low rounds so one
round captures a one-round LS plus
captures love us theta function for the
independent set problem you can also use
it for vertex cover and in the gomin
williamson relaxation of max cut and
three rounds of LS plus captures the arv
sparse this cuts so kind of the best
that we have fell very low in these
hierarchies so they seemed to be they
seemed to capture things that people
care about okay so
I want to yeah I want to talk a little
bit about different results and kind of
in the in the proof so these these
hierarchy systems can be thought of as
proof systems and so what you need in
this result you need in it I said you
need a counter example and then you have
to have a proof that the counter example
has no combinatorial solution and the
proof that this kind of proof system
fails at at seeing that so you actually
that one of the themes is you need a
stronger proof system to prove than
these things to prove that the
combinatorial example has no small
vertex cover right because this fails to
see that has no small vertex cover so
you need a stronger kind of proof to
show that and an interesting kind of way
of thinking with these results is what
kind of techniques are they using and
what kind of graphs using what
techniques are they using on these
graphs to show that no small vertex
cover exists so kind of outsmart these
proof systems okay and so in the first
two examples we saw I said use this
Frankel rutul graph which is this kind
of the proof is this kind of messy
combinatorial proof that kind of when
you change things just slightly
geometrically they change radically in
the vertex cover case the next result
I'll talk about very briefly is x over
all of us lavasa entrelac ease no two
and they I think this was the first
paper that really showed what you could
do with these things and show that you
could produce pretty robust lower bounds
and they showed that the integrality up
of two remains even after log and rounds
of lavash reverse so there's no there's
no pun only time algorithm it's going to
fit lavash of our hierarchy and what
they used was a random graph of a large
girth so next I'll talk very briefly
about this result of mine and Luca trev
zonin in Madrid luciani that extends
this result to order n rounds so I think
this surprise people bit saying that
these linear programs a large class of
linear programs actually can't solve
vertex cover two approximation factor
better than two and
exponential time and not only can't do
that it can't do it on random graphs so
kind of random graphs are enough to fool
linear programs and maybe this is
interesting because random graphs can't
fool semi definite programs right the
Lavasa theta function which falls in the
first round of LS plus is not fooled by
random graphs it kind of sees this graph
is random you know it has it looks at
this eigen values and it says there's no
way this thing has a small vertex cover
but they fool very deep into the into
the LS hierarchy so I'm going to go over
this proof for just a little bit to show
you one particular part of it so the
graph is we're going to the graph we're
going to use as a counter example for
this Alice our keys or is a random graph
and we're going to modify a little bit
you don't have to but will so that it
has large girth so you just have to
remove a few edges of a random graph and
you get a graph with large girth that
means there's no small sigh clinic and
what that means is that any kind of any
any sub graph if you look at if you pick
a point and you look locally around it
looks like a tree right and also a
property that that's used in this is
that is a small sub graphs are sparse so
if you look at at a any induced sub
graph that contains only a small
fraction of the vertices then that that
sub graph doesn't have many cycles it
has just a few more it can it has just a
few more edges than it has vertices so
it can't have many cycles so it's it's
almost a tree it's just a little more
complicated than a tree also random
graphs do not have small vertex covers
at least regular ground
Jim uh just uh GMP what be
uh let's see I don't I'm thinking it's
constant but I don't remember like like
the expected number of vertices would be
constant but I I don't really recall
yeah i can i can tell you later but i'll
have to look it up I mean you just you
need enough so that this doesn't hold
right and then you can show that the
solution of putting weight kind of just
over one half on every vertex survives
many many rounds and this gives you the
integrality gap of two because almost
all the vertices are required to be the
vertex cover but the linear programming
solution says that only half of them are
and so I'll show you how how to survive
one round of this and this is different
than the than the result before the
Aurora Bella wash lavasa interlock ease
because they did things very implicitly
with kind of duels of linear programs
and we did things explicitly so go back
to that model of the adversary kind of
pointing at vertices and you
conditioning on them so the adversary
points at some vertex in the graph and
you have to condition on that vertex
being in the covering you have to say
what happens when the vertex is in the
cover and when it's not in the cover and
what we're going to want is we're going
to want to only change an area in in
kind of a small ball around that vertex
in a constant size ball around that
vertex and the way we're going to do it
is this in that constant size ball the
it looks like a tree and we're going to
imagine this process being run on the
tree the process is this if the if your
parent is zero then you're one with
probability 1 and if your parent is 1
then most of the time you're 0 but some
of the time you're one so this is like
noisy transmission of data down a tree
ok and these values are picked so that
if you're one with probably one half
plus epsilon then your child is 1 with
probability one-half plus epsilon ok
recap how high and what's the depth of
these trees I'd you can just come
together it's constant constant death
yeah we of each vertex is about this is
the question I failed that you've all
asked earlier it's a constant for now
but it won't it won't matter so this is
a very sparse right to the back uh yeah
it's you you need it's just it's just
dense enough that it has no small vertex
covers that's what that's what you need
you need to put enough edges so you get
this combinatorial proof that there's no
small vertex cover via it goes via just
a normal kind of Chernoff bound ii
argument
yeah so the fact that the galaxies of
awakening has nothing to do with
excitement it's just fine
you need to remove a few edges to make
the girth large but you can you can show
that you remove square root edges in the
graph is large okay so on this on this
part of the graph this little circle
that we cut out this is actually a
distribution of vertex covers right I
mean trees have small vertex covers
right you can always cover them with
half and in particular this is a
distribution of vertex covers that
includes about one-half plus epsilon of
the vertices and so because I gave a
true distribution if I condition on this
I know what happens it's just what
happens in this distribution so my
condition on it you know if I get it if
this is in the cover then the second row
these are very unlikely to be in the
cover these are very likely to be in a
cover but as I go down further and
further this epsilon bit of noise that I
add at each level adds up and if you get
a constant number of rounds I get very
very close to the levels kind of being
the same and everything being one half
plus epsilon again right because it's
this noisy transmission so what do i do
then within the circle of the graph i
give this distribution which is a
distribution of vertex covers so it's
definitely allowed outside i leave
everything one half plus epsilon and
across because because the edges across
the one inside is about one half plus
epsilon the one outside is about one
half plus epsilon the requirement is
that the sum be greater than one it's
always greater than one I survive on the
on the bounty on that boundary too but
it turns out that this kind of crossing
the edge and throwing it away while it
works in LS gives you trouble later and
other in other models and I'll talk
about that later so I'm not going to
have time to talk more about this except
to say that so this kind of this shows
you that you can survive one round with
this kind of splash with local
modification as long as the splashes are
far apart I can always locally modify
the part of the graph I care about and
condition on another vertex and survive
another round and
you it's kind of tricky but if the
splashes get close together you can
actually use a trick to kind of fix all
the vertices that are involved and make
the new splash as far apart and that's
that's and you can interns that you can
kind of survive this game for quite a
while
ok
right so that's all I want to say about
about this LS I think I'm vertex cover
the next couple results are these and
these are kind of interesting that all
use different instances and I'll talk
about each of them very briefly so the
first result is this this was my guy in
effect and and what Fagin affected as
they said let's try to refute a 3x3 set
formula and the way we're going to try
to refute a three set formula is we're
going to use the standard deduction
we're going to make it into a pink the
next slide I have fuchsia use the
standard reduction and we're going to
make it into an independent set problem
and then we're going to run the las
tetas function on the independent set
problem and we're going to see what kind
of 3sat random 3sat formulas we can
refute and there is a standard reduction
called FG LSS and you replace each 3sat
clause is replaced by one of these
gadgets here actually I did it for 3x or
so 3x or so you have X or clauses so x1
plus x2 plus x3 goes one to produce it
by this little gadget this for click and
so here X 1 is kind of 0 x2 is 0 and X 3
is 1 and these are the four satisfying
assignments here so you create a one of
these cleats for each clause and then
you connect the edges that are that
contradict each other so for example
here this one says X 3 is 1 this one
says X 3 is 0 so there's a line between
them they should be connected and then
you can show that if the solution is
satisfiable then there's an independent
set of size a fourth of the graph
because I just include the ones that the
the vertices that correspond to the
satisfying solution and if it's not know
such things this so then if I can show
if the theta function can show that no
you know no satisfying assignment or no
independent set of size of orthographic
cysts then I can refute the 3sat formula
and actually show that this works kind
of as well as as as the other kind of
good
techniques to review three sub formulas
but no better okay so that's what
they're doing but implicitly what they
did is actually gave a 76 minus epsilon
integrality gap for vertex cover by
reducing from these three X or and in
this paper by again madura luke and I we
showed that actually you can you can
amplify this to survive order n rounds
of LS plus for the same integrality gap
so this shows that kind of you know sub
no sub exponential in your program
algorithm is going to you know exactly
compute vertex cover and in within LS
these reductions don't work very well
and so you have to kind of reprove
everything so we kind of the first the
proof there's a proof that LS plus
doesn't work for a 3x or by elective it
you are interlocked e so we kind of took
that and combined it with a Phi go
effect to get this result here I'm
actually here I'll brief juggalos
reasonably well GM PT Georgia my ghum
petoskey interlock ease and they showed
that actually on the same Frankel roto
graph you can survive a super constant
number of rounds of LS plus and you get
an A Grave of two minus Epsilon now I
told you that before I would say
something about the heirs and what
happens to these errors I don't either
kind of hard to deal with so the the
semi definite constraints that you get
from LS plus they introduce a kind of
global constraint you can't just modify
things locally anymore if you modify a
little bit of something after my
something up something else to make that
the program some positive semi-definite
and so the way we did it is we showed
that kind of actually with these three x
or instances you can just modify things
locally and there's because you're not
so close to the gap this error dies very
soon and there's there's no air in this
paper here what they did is they they
showed that you get these ripples and
they go throughout the entire graph and
what you can do is after each round you
just kind of round down
to where the lowest ripple is and
because the because of this month
because the monotonicity of the
constraints you can always round down
without punishing yourself but you
survived a lot fewer rounds when you do
that and the next result which I think
you guys saw which by chair Cormac our
chat Makar cheb they show it for sure
Ollie Adams lets you minus epsilon they
also use the random graph and they
reduce the noise by using this really
clever way that that I guess use them a
trick from metric embeddings to kind of
show that the noise doesn't matter again
you lose something in the number of
rounds its end of the epsilon but you
gain because you don't have to the straw
Adams right you can't you can't switch
the order the order can't matter for you
so it's much stronger constraint and
they they were able to survive to show
that these stronger constraints don't
work in this way about the 76 so hoping
anything this
and it says that it takes a few places
Omega and I anything that's concerned
that's just implied by my house result
right just because
it's 1.3 something oh right yeah right
so that's a the fake it was out he's
actually immediately strongly result is
it blind just I think um not well okay
so that's a really good question and the
answer is that that's true if you assume
that P does not equal NP right so if you
assume that right yeah so and if you
assume that if you assume that there's
no subject no sub exponential algorithm
for np-hard problems then then this
result is also implied alright so
depends how strong of assumptions you
want to make about NP so kind of one
neat thing about these things is that
their unconditional the other neat thing
is that you get this stratification of
you know sub exponential or quasi
polynomial ER or whatever but yeah
that's a great point okay so the last oh
boy last result that I'll I guess I'm a
little low on time so I'll just mention
is that actually you can I was able to
strengthen this result which tells plus
for Lasserre and this is the first
integrality gap for the ser hierarchy so
that's the strongest of the hierarchies
and it survives actually order n rounds
and gets you this 7 6 minus epsilon and
it the kind of neat thing about it is
that it comes from a proof that X or in
a random X or formula can't be refuted
by Lasserre so let me just say so the
theorem is that a random acts or
instance is not refuted even by a linear
number rounds lists there and so the the
proof is that a random 3x well from the
can't be refuted by with W resolution
and this was shown by Ben saason and
vigor ssin and then and then I was able
to show that actually if it has no width
W resolution veceras kind of no stronger
than with W resolution now the other
side of it how do you prove that a
random direction or formula is
unsatisfiable
it comes from just the just turn off to
our arguments and it and it seems that
like I guess it seems that it's odd that
you can like the other one is odd that
you can fool semi-definite programs
using random things but kind of the
reason seems to be is that you're using
random hypergraphs instead of random
actual graphs and the semi definite
programs don't pick these up very well
okay so yeah you guys miss out on a
beautiful proof i'm sorry but another
neat thing about lasserre is that
reductions actually work quite well
endless there and so the coral area of
the resultant 3x or is actually you get
this integrality gap for vertex cover
immediately from it and it's not like LS
plus we had to kind of reprove things a
little bit the the end of the story for
for today on this is is a is murder
tulsi on e actually went showed you
could take these these vectors from
local constraint satisfaction problems
and push them through the dinner
software reduction that showed NP
hardness result and actually get the
same integrality gap result though it
because the size of the program the size
of the graph instance increases you you
only get it for end of the epsilon
rounds which means that actually on this
slide there's five like incomparable
best best integrality gaps so i think
it's kind of and still lots of room for
improvement
so kind of from a higher level sdp
hierarchies why do we care about them
while they're related approximation
algorithms and some of these problems or
toy problems like vertex cover maybe but
some are problems people care about like
sparse this cut they provide
unconditional lower bounds so you don't
have to wait for people to prove that P
does not equal NP to show that our
techniques are feeble they're they're
related to proof complexity in kind of
fun ways and kind of you know you're
trying to come up with kind of things
that fool you know what these
hierarchies and kind of more imaginative
ways to prove that there's no solution
we also related to local global trade
offs if the if you look at likes Raleigh
Adams it defines local distribution so
it's kind of saying locally everything
looks good but globally things are amiss
so this goes to a long kind of
mathematical mathematic tradition of
looking at local global trade offs and
when is looking at something locally
tell you something about the global
structure of it and that's definitely
present here and the last thing is
average case hardness maybe not as it's
traditionally meant but you can look and
see when the interval at a gap is large
look for which instances it's large so
here you and a lot of these results were
able to show that kind of four random
instance the integrality gap is large or
you might be able to sometimes you can
show that for like a suitably dense
instance it's not large so we can we can
actually solve dense instance as well or
things like like that so you can you can
start breaking down kind of the then p
hardness results by saying on this
subset we can actually do something
substantial um that's all I want to say
about NP hardness results I'll talk to
you some of you later so I've done other
recent work should I so question should
I and now is told about 50 minutes or
should I go on for a little longer or
okay okay so i'll i'll just make it a
little longer so i have other work we
proved a new yet another proof of the
xor lemma with thomas Wallenstein and
it's kind of fun because it's real
a simple and easy and it has
applications to taking combining
cryptographic protocols and rerunning
like a week bit commitment protocol
several times and strengthening it also
work on online algorithms for non
monotone submodular maximization can't
hardly read all those words but the kind
of idea there is like so you have a sec
the hiring problem or the secretary
problem where you want to pick the
largest element of asset and now instead
of picking largest element of asset
you're trying to hire I don't know like
postdocs and they all have different
strengths and weaknesses but you don't
get any reward if if their strengths
overlap you only count them once right
you we already have an expert in blah
blah blah we don't need it we don't need
another one so now your maximization
your function submodular it's kind of a
set cover problem and you can only hire
three and so you want and you hire them
kind of sequentially once you let one go
you can't hire the next one and so you
want to maximize that it worked on
property testing with reed-solomon codes
and I'll talk a very briefly about
arriving at consensus and social
networks with Al Capone muzzle and and
then in a this is older work but Nash
equilibrium concisely represented games
so you have a game and it's not all the
payoffs aren't written out explicitly
maybe it's computed by circuit maybe
it's a graphical game maybe it's another
funky kind of game called an action
graph game which kind of captures local
dependencies and you want to solve
questions related to Nash equilibrium
and there's kind of hardness results
there so I'll talk just briefly kind of
mention this work on arriving at
consensus on social networks so the
story is there's a group of kids and
they want to go to movie and these are
two movie theaters from my hometown you
have the war on old town and the warrant
east side and they need to pick which
movie theater go-to but they don't all
know each other and maybe it'll bump
together in the hallways and I want to
pick between these otherwise
indistinguishable things but is very
important
everyone was the same one otherwise no
one's going to have any fun and the
question we look at or what are the kind
of computational issues to doing this so
assuming no game theoretic problems
these people are clever incurring any
algorithm they want what kind of what
are there any inherent kind of
computational boundaries to this um it
was motivated by some experimental work
where they basically they put people in
front of a computer and you can maybe
see what color your neighbor chose and
you're trying to reach a consensus or
you're trying to color a graph so choose
something opposite them and and and so
there's kind of a series of works here
which I won't go into any more of it
said they're kind of interesting and the
definitely fun reads if you want some
fun in your life so this is so in this
is a the model very briefly you have a
you have a weighted network this is it
number five people so I gave this ICS I
was in China that's my brother he's a
professor to everyone has it as a state
of their own and the each edge is
equipped with a Poisson clock and the
rate of the Poisson clock is equal to
the weight of the edge so when an edge
rings one of us on clock rings then it's
like the two people are talking to each
other right so they talk to each other
they may be flip some random coins and
they update their states based on of the
coin tosses and the previous states and
the the other important thing is that
this update function has to treat the
two kind of choices the consensus the
same right so a lot of times in
distributed computing the way that you
compute consensus is you can feel like
the order things that's not allowed here
because that doesn't treat them the same
so there's there's no difference between
the two theaters except that it really
matters which one we go to but otherwise
they're indistinguishable and so within
this kind of and also as a we often
parametrize it by the size of the state
so if they have one bit for a state or
two bits for state or
log n bits for state what can they do
and the problems we study are kind of
our coordination so they all want to
arrive at the same solution so there's
some special state red or blue and they
need to all right that red are all
arrived at blue majority coordination
which is simply computing the majority
of some original single they're given
and we it's um it's kind of interesting
that one of the important kind of
definitions or parameters for this
problem is what we call the broadcast
time and I think this this differs a
little bit from some of the distributed
computing stuff because of this so the
broadcast time is the time for message
to flood the network so kind of if I
start sending out something really
outrageous so that everyone will send it
how long does it take for that message
to reach the entire network and this
because we use these Poisson clocks
which are kind of goofy it seems to
depend on the like maybe it behaves more
like the expansion than the diameter and
that if there's a lot many paths for for
a message to reach somewhere it'll
actually get there much faster than it
will if there's just one short path and
actually this it turns out this
broadcast time is is is about is the
right like you can you can do consensus
with a constant number of bits in the
broadcast time so I want to go over too
much but just briefly something results
so with one bit you can do it and kind
of slowly an N squared time but you can
do it this coordination and but actually
in constant number of bits you can you
can you can compute it in the broadcast
time which is maybe that as fast as
you'd expect to be able to compute it
and I won't show you any of stuff what
you guys are missing out here all right
the majority coordination it turns out
is impossible to do with one bit but
it's kind of fun you can actually do it
with two bits and again it's kind of
more mixing time it's this
a little like and cube stuff but you can
you can actually do it with not many
more bits you need to log you need to
kind of remember a neighbor essentially
but if you're going to remember a
neighbor then you can do it with in time
of the base on the diameter not the
broadcast time at the diameter and plus
some login factors assumption of the
geometry wait so there's no assumption
on the on the geometry here but a lot of
times like so this n cubed well this is
like a worst-case so um it'll be much
faster on most graphs than n cubed you'd
think interesting families of that I
know so we this is kind of the first
shot of doing this and and probably
makes more sense to to get the model
working better before the fork spending
too much time on the map for specific
graphs but some some cases would be
interesting to look at right
I mean a lot of times like with the with
the coordination kind of the broadcast
time seems to capture a large bit of the
geometry of a graph right like how long
it takes a message get from one side of
the network to the other says something
about the way the network is is made up
if there's like one link between them
you got to wait for that one guy to go
off it's likely to take a lot longer
than if it's well connected all right um
so kind of like I just want to mention
this work is it's kind of in its infancy
right it's just like we propose this
kind of fun model and showed some stuff
on it and in the future this is is kind
of I think it'll be interesting like you
can try to make the model fit the
experimental results better and what and
what people did actually you can try to
modify the experimental results to fit
the model a little bit better and and
what I mean by that is that a lot of the
experiments everyone just had one bit
they were communicating with one bit and
we showed that actually the strategies
that we show that that converge quick
some of them are very natural but
require more than one bit of
communication so you couldn't employ
these in these networks and so maybe
they're not very good models of the way
people interact and so the experiments
could be tweaked a big thing is is
subbing things one is a availability how
do the agents learn what algorithms to
run this we just say like you run this
like weird algorithm like go right this
doesn't seem to be very realistic and it
could be improved upon a lot putting
game theory in it maybe I don't care
about only care if my friends are
they're not friends of their friends
maybe I'll cheat and run a different
model if it's better for me and also we
used bounded rationality by bounding the
memory of these it's it's the first hack
at things but of course you know a
two-bit finite state machine doesn't
exactly replicate human and there's many
you know ways that that can fail so
other you know other what are other ways
that we can try to do
better yeah and also just to go beyond
consensus because consensus like the
easiest thing you can think of it's
great because as you add an edge in the
graph the problem doesn't change the
problem notices all is the same to reach
consensus whereas like with coloring
problems it does so you have two moving
targets it makes a lot harder but but so
there's lots of there's lots of work in
the in the future in this area in it if
you all want to talk about it today and
the interview is I'd be happy to discuss
it with you so that's all I want to say
thanks
ok questions thank you